the president though already is getting
a lot of pushback from members of
Congress on this do you think this deal
that you negotiate in Atlanta is going
to survive next year in Congress well I
do this is a very good deal it levels
the playing field for American workers
and American firms right now we already
have an open economy our average tariff
is about 1.4 percent eighty percent of
the goods that come into our country
from TPP countries already comes in
duty-free but we face tariffs of seventy
percent on our auto exports fifty-five
percent on our engines fifty percent are
machinery and all of those are going to
go to zero so it's about protecting
American jobs here by tearing down
barriers abroad increasing exports
supporting good well-paying jobs here
and then leveling the playing field by
raising labor and environmental
standards in other countries so that our
workers and our firms based here in the
United States have a more fair chance of
competing in the global economy could
you have done a better job though my
goal in telling this to the American
public because it's not just the NBC
poll that says this but a pew center
poll last year I had the same results a
yougov poll earlier the summer also
showed the same results and that
Americans do not want more trade well
usually when we when we taught at the
American public can explain how we're
tearing down barriers abroad creating
more opportunities for high quality
American exports and that's going to
drive more jobs and higher wages here in
the United States they'll be supportive
and we're looking forward to the
agreement being being published having
everyone have an opportunity to read it
in detail and then make an informed
decision about their perspective on it
will be consulting with Congress with
the public with stakeholders and and
going around the country and
underscoring the benefits for every
state in every sector a Bernie Sanders
said this about the about the agreement
quote wall street and other big
corporations have won again it is time
for the rest of us to stop letting
multinational corporations rig the
system to pad their profits at our
expense well I don't have a license to
practice presidential politics all say
is that this is a very good agreement
for American workers farmers ranchers as
I said we live in an open economy here
we're tearing down barriers to our
exports
broad were raising standards abroad in
terms of labor and environment
intellectual property and other
standards and I can only benefit the
American worker and the American public
okay so you may not want to talk
presidential politics but let's talk
about the history of free trade here
NAFTA is looked as a shining example of
how free trade hasn't worked it has
according to some reports shown a loss
of American jobs it wasn't executed well
and this is partly the reason why these
polls show that Americans don't want
another free trade agreement well when
President Obama was running for
president kennedy obama's running for
president he said he wanted to
renegotiate NAFTA and he talked about
making labor and environmental standards
poor to a trade agreement and making
them fully enforceable and that's
exactly what TPP does TPP is the
renegotiation of NAFTA but not just with
Mexico and Canada but with forty percent
of the global economy who will now have
to have higher standards fully
enforceable through this trade agreement